ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dillon show we are here in New York City
with my personal trainer my guest a man
who's changed my life
it was made me understand that you know
you can you can indulge but you just
have to be accountable you have to hold
yourself accountable we we're doing the
sixth cheat day a week system yeah
halcus court house is Fitness
by the way like every every Boomer diet
always failed because every Boomer diet
was like based on this crazy premise
which was the entire Boomer ecosystem
was all about themselves so every diet
was literally like they're like every
diet like that my mother would explain
to me and she'd be like no no no no I
can have anything I want right I just
have to be accountable yeah yeah so if I
have a chocolate cake then I just have a
glass of water later on that's that's
the that's such fat logic too where it's
like I remember just get my go-to move
on the road was like well I'll get wings
but I'm getting a salad as well right
and to me that's like equals out yeah
completely equals out yeah that's some
immigrant [__] too of like yeah it will
make you a fourth a six course meal
spaghetti to open open up lamb chops you
know what I mean a soup a chowder but
then we got a nice light Romaine
afterwards yeah we're good to go and
they're fine yeah you'll be okay it's
like such a [__]
it's uh it's a mind [__] out there it's
now we were talking about the rider
strike uh for before we started which I
know none of my fans have an interest in
they tell me that right you know they're
like I don't want a theater kid [__] off
I don't want gay Hollywood imaginations
I don't want gay Hollywood stuff I'm
just wondering because you are a labor
leader that's right what do you know
what's going on I don't you don't I have
no [__] clue I mean come on dude
where's Hassan what's going on give them
what they want my guess is just writers
once everything became digital uh they
were just like oh this is something we
don't there's no rules so we just won't
pay anyone right that's almost certainly
what happened and you hear about with
animation where they're like they're
like okay uh we're just gonna get you
know 6 000 Taiwanese 12 year olds right
to render each image instead of paying
like real animators or you know just
like yeah they're just anywhere they can
[__] your ass they will anywhere they
can take it yeah and I have a I have a
thing happening now and my interest in
this isn't selfish it's for the other
people nobody loves writers more than me
nobody loves a Hollywood sitcom right
now nobody love the Hollywood sitcom
writer they've all been said lovely
things about me on Twitter they've said
very nice things about my friend Joe
Rogan I mean nobody's closer with the
Echo Park Silver Lake yes Riders crew
and I am so my concern is for them I
wish some of them looked funnier well
not that they're all comedy writers but
in that can you bring up that wga thing
on Twitter
you know it just I I didn't feel bad
they're not great at the marketing angle
they should have had like Andrew Schultz
direct the wga like writer's kill
because it's just like Sad Sack hipster
pieces of [__] right being like it's not
right and you're like oh God you wanted
a little more levity I wanted just you
know a whoopee cushion I wanted them to
just make just make people care because
I got a thing now with a one of these
writers good person
and he's like you know he's gonna do it
he's gonna strike I get it but then
we're gonna be [__] so it's Long
Island call me by your name it's a long
island call me by yourself everyone's
obese it's very thinnest man in the
kitchen very fat call me well I was
talking about this the other day I was
talking about the trans thing the other
day and I saw you and Theo a little bit
and I'm like is it one of the issues
that some of them are like getting fat
because I think that like any minority
can't be fat in the beginning right like
if gay people had come out and then
immediately just like got in League with
fat activism nobody like they accepted
hot gay men first yeah you got it yeah
theirs were not the first no they're not
the Marines of being accepted they're
not the tip of the spear no you don't
throw the fats out you got a piece of
ass you gotta you gotta It's gotta be
like hot people first because like then
like straight people start calling you
know I might [__] that guy oh and then
all of a sudden they're like okay maybe
let's not kill that person right right
but you know when right when fats start
getting involved people start it's it
becomes like now you're fighting a war
on two fronts right right right no no
you're absolutely right and I agree with
you Tim fat phobia one of the biggest
issues we're facing today it is without
question it is atrocious
first of all planes should only have
what 20 people I would say one seat I
would say each plane should have like
eight like big but he was a big man and
myself I I call us people of size yeah
but we understand that the fat activism
is a little much it's getting a little
much you know I agree with that I
understand that uh people are upset at
it no nobody should be abusing fat but
you shouldn't be walking around and you
know abusing them but we can't do what
does that look like walking around
talking about it in my act you know in
the 80s and 90s fat women just kind of
beauty
and there are people that want to go
back to that because they're monsters
right but uh we can't demand that the
entire world remake themselves for the
fat people but I would say if you had it
look yeah if you put the fat consumer
forward on in an airline oh I think the
consumer is fine if you put the back if
you put the packet super on the
Forefront yeah everyone's having a
better time right a little extra leg
room I I I don't need law I don't need
more leg room I need more width right
you know what I'm saying on a plane seat
you're telling me that wouldn't be nice
if you're some skinny piece of [__] to
be honest I really really open up those
[__] I think that that if a fat
person were to design a plane yeah you
would even the thin people would have a
lot more fun a lot more fun it's a good
point the airlines would lose some money
they'd lose a lot of money
would be the healthiest option the fact
that there's a cookie with no cream
involved there's no chocolate chip they
give us that glorified wafer and and
they tell us that's that's dessert well
you're in first class I'm In First Class
it's better it's much better it's the
only luxury I'll never give up I will
live on the street but I will never give
up the first class you get on First
Class you're like oh you think this is
going to be the best flight of my life
and you're like oh they treat you like a
human being yes and that's it that's
what first class is it's just being
treated like a human being when you were
in the back of the plane which I was for
years in a middle seat wherever I could
be is there anything worse no then when
you are uh on the aisle and the guy it
feels like fully full fully full plane
yeah and they're like this plane is
mostly full and you're like [__]
someone's gonna sit here
it's late it's already done you're like
oh my God people are they've [__]
their flight attends are putting
everything up you're like is this
happening is this really gonna happen
and then you see someone Rush on the
plane and there's elated they made their
flight last second and then the second
they see they're sitting next to you all
that Joy is gone they're like I should
have just missed it and I had an aisle
to myself I sat once on a plane this is
I'm not even kidding yeah with two of
the fattest guys
in a row
it was to the point where and we were in
by the way yeah in a row that was like
you know there's first class and then
there's like the the you know the first
Comfort plus whatever it is we were in
one of those first rows so the people
all all looked at us as they were
walking back every like an attraction at
the zoo
every single person looked at that row
where it is like God damn it look
because it never happens where you have
three huge guys it was three big dudes
they're like earn an extra cook if you
can tell us where his thighs end and his
begin yeah
that's one mass of Flesh not one of us
looked at each other
and not one of us said anything to each
other and all of our faces were
rage oh dude I've actually been there
when I get a fat guy next to me I'm like
the airline should step in what the [__]
is this the government I'll turn into a
Marxist right now the government
look if there was a child in first yeah
they gotta switch the fatty in the
middle seat with that [__] like with
that kid trust my kid I hate by the way
I hate children you should never be
allowed hate them should never be I hate
them on their iPads yeah I hate them so
much I hate the attitudes they already
have 100 telling the ho like telling the
flight attendant like uh just ordering
them around away you would be like
embarrassing it's horrible or apple
juice yeah it's disgusting I hate when a
family's in first class and I go oh all
of you or I've my family was never in
first class no so when I see an entire
Rich family In First Class almost
despicable kids have to be you want to
get them Comfort plus fine right I
cannot be in first if I was a rich
parent I would just throw the kids in
the back okay go guys have some fun
there be independent right do some stuff
you know whatever you want to do this is
your taste of what reality this is
reality man for four hours at a time
you'll get it and never again yeah
otherwise it's like it's it's absolutely
ridiculous
um do you think Bud Light suffers long
term for this or have they even stuff
like everyone's going they've lost six
billion dollars I guess that's stock
yeah valuation how do we even know that
yet I don't even know how we know also
didn't they I didn't I wasn't really
paying attention obviously I don't give
a [__] that much right but apparently it
was just like I thought they said they
made like a trans person they're like
spokesman that was like one thing it was
like they bought an ad on some girl's
Instagram yeah and everybody blew it up
it's like how dare they and it's so you
got to think for if you believe in like
the no prep all press is good press yeah
everyone's talking about Bud Light you
got a lot you got recharge buying them
to shoot them with AK-47s and then you
have gay people [__] you know yeah
doing doing body loses body shots
right now yeah you know and then you got
me I'll sip a little Bud Light I could
lose a dumbass about it because Luis
Gomez is Lucia Gomez the proprietor of
the gas station
I called him and I talked to because I
always talk to him about like stuff like
Brands and marketing or whatever like
what do you think's going on here and he
was like ultimately he thinks it's a
great move that like when when Rogan was
having his thing with Spotify there were
thousands of articles that said the word
Spotify and podcast in the same article
right all of a sudden people now think
of Spotify as the place for podcasts
where they never did before even though
there was controversy there was this
huge so I'm wondering now if people are
just you know if long term it's better
what if they go not maybe maybe just
maybe next is like OJ like keep going oh
that would be sick keep doing very
controversial which I really should be a
Pitch man yeah what's he doing he's one
of the most well-adjusted people I've
seen I mean to be honest I mean it's
crazy yeah he's one of the most like if
you see him on Twitter like of course he
makes good points he's always like happy
smile on his face relax and because I
think he did what he he wanted to do
like yeah he was like how many people
could kill someone who's bothering them
get away get away with it and then on
the other side be like okay yeah I mean
that's got look morality aside it's got
to feel awesome to get away with and not
just not even just like he planned it
out he was studying for years it was
like he did it it was so clear the way
it was supposed to be done everyone knew
he murdered he probably saw her and him
[__] through the window and went
tonight didn't he kill like her gay
friend not the guy she [__] no Ron
Goldman was the guy she was [__] and
he I think one of the theories is that
he saw them through the window right
right and was like it's on and then he
went in there and you know cut their
heads off yeah we tried him again
that that being said I've never seen a
person on social media that I I feel is
in a better place yeah he's happy and
look he's amazing if you kill someone
and you get away with it so publicly
it's like unless we're forgetting the
man is a Hall of Fame running back the
man is
that people will never be he's an actor
that's his third running back he's been
in uh he was he was almost gonna be the
Terminator oh he was a finalist for the
Terminator before Schwarzenegger got it
he's in all the uh uh the Naked Gun
movies I might have to put him forth in
my most American lives I have uh the the
people that have lived lives that could
really only be possible in America and
my my top three it's in the water but
it's Donald Trump yeah Caitlyn Jenner
right and Alex Jones and I might have to
put O.J Simpson as fourth in terms of
like lives that are really only possible
in America for my money dude he might be
right under DT he might be because I
agree with you because yeah oh I mean
just truly a star in a USC we haven't
even thought about all the [__] he got
oh you know I mean he killed it he's got
it literally but he's and now now he's
just in Vegas having a good time nobody
he's become this like and I think if
people see him out now like I gotta be
honest with you I'm over it I think a
lot of people are over it I think a lot
of to be honest I mean I know what
you're saying you know what I mean at
the same time there's levels to that
statement because you're you know having
a life we're having a nice little time
here but at the same time
I see him on I see him online and I
don't think there's a murderer I don't I
don't have any anger towards him I think
listen OJ's got a towards that man if I
saw him in Vegas gentlemen if you didn't
already know it's tax season here in the
U.S manscape does work here's the thing
about manscape yeah it really is good
right I mean it's one of those I sell a
lot of products here I believe in all of
them
important that it's tax season by the
way you know you don't want to pay your
taxes with hairy nuts that's the thing
your boys downstairs are having fun make
sure you spend your holiday tax money on
the important things this year like
family friends and Bowl deodorant
join me join the 8 million men worldwide
to trust man's camping going to
manscape.com you get 20 off uh with the
code 83 weeks and you get free shipping
20 off with the code 83 weeks we know
what it is it's a great product I've
used it it's great I mean everybody
likes it I use it everyone uses it and
um a funny shaving story that's a good
idea that's a good problem one time yeah
my friend uses another uses the
Walgreens right he uses the wall groomer
right and here's a problem with that
it's not it doesn't have the skin safe
technology yeah that manscape does so he
was drunk and in the tub
with a wall groomer and he cut off his
[__]
bled out he bled out he was saved
but he's he's trans now because he said
to his wife if it's gone let's just
explore other things yeah she was
weirdly down she's bi so he has a [__]
but two nuts yeah but two nuts and a
puss and she loves it and she's jamming
them all the time and she just [__] the
[__] out of him with a strap-on it's
fine but that's a bad thing by the way
but if you're not but that's right
and it's a one in a month
he says his life is better he says his
life is much better but what are the
chances it happens to you not high so I
would say Kim D is the code the code is
Tim D it's not anything it's Tim D the
code is Tim D that was a joke earlier on
the thing
um
um so get 20 off free shipping with the
code Tim D at manscape.com that's 20 off
plus free shipping at the
codemanscape.com don't just get your
money back this year get your Swagger
back too with manscapes
I would be excited I would kind of be
really excited I'd be like hey OJ like
hey can I get a photo I'm a really big
fan no legit just for the Instagram
I mean how many people are doing that by
the way everybody's probably doing that
100 and imagine him thinking like when
he's standing there you know in court
and all this horrible stuff's coming out
I wonder if he thought like hey man this
is all gonna shake out yeah one day
Donald Trump will be the president
right Bruce Jenner will transition to
Caitlyn and then I'm gonna be in Vegas
and people are going to be actually
coming up to me going hey I'm a big fan
the nelk boys had him on the podcast
he's kind of rehabilitated
he's kind of rehabilitated I would
literally go up to O.J Simpson and go I
am a huge fan and I would love a photo I
would get and I'm very confident he
decapitated his wife and her lover but I
would I would absolutely go up to him
and go I am a huge big fan massive fan
of yours
can I get a photo and then I would put
it on my Instagram and try to come up
with a funny caption and I think you
figure it out that's how over it I am of
course I'm kind of over it I wouldn't do
that with Dylan roof sure I wouldn't do
that with someone I think is like I
think Dylan roof is evil yeah and
because I think he went any targeted
People based on their race 100 and I
think that's that there's something
inherently evil about a person who walks
into a church yeah but a house in
Brentwood where you're second off a
waiter and a church that ain't a church
and there's just different it's not a
church and I'm I'm not saying it's right
and that's not right but is it Apostle
worship no yeah here's another fun yeah
if you really want to spin and you
really want to start getting crazy with
it being pro OJ
the reason he what's one of the biggest
signs of CTE is damage is brain damage
it's aggression it's violence so not
only that you could make him like like
by the way the NFL when O.J Simpson dies
will drop a nuclear bomb on the funeral
home that he's in so that science
doesn't get a hold of his brain right
because it like truly he got he went
crazy because he was one of the best I
mean dude that [__] was playing
when they had like one Strat one helmet
right you know I mean they had like one
little thing was getting hit and taking
heads all the time yeah he's a gladiator
for your enjoyment in many ways if you
love the NFL you killed Nicole Brown
Simpson and a lot of people are okay
with that if you put it in those terms a
lot of people are okay with that I gotta
be honest because number one people hate
LA right they hate laws
there's never been a city that is hated
more kind of justifiably than La no one
cares
a woman now this might be wrong this is
probably wrong but a woman who's seen as
a gold digger
is not going to get the same level of
sympathy as the juice then as it as The
Talented uh man who's made the money I'm
not hey did I make the world am I God
I'm reporting what happens if anything
this is a news show this is a I'm a
media figure and I'm reporting the news
litigating the O.J Simpson murders I'm
going to be a gas digital Studio I gotta
be honest with you there's not a man I'd
be more excited to see in Las Vegas
there's no could you think of a person
in Las Vegas you'd be happier to see
than OJ [__] Simpson no not I mean I
guess Carrot Top Christmas I would ask
him for weight loss advice
I would I would hold myself accountable
I may text OJ my steps every now
that's how much I respect you want an
ongoing relationship I love the naked
guns so like there's a there's a version
of me that's at the end of every night
going OJ I only got 7 500 in today
because I'm on the road he's like don't
worry about it brother try to hit 12
tomorrow we all make mistakes try to hit
12 000 tomorrow he's like keep the carbs
you know after 3 P.M no carbs yeah yeah
yeah I
let's let me also just throw this out
please and this might not
is he the worst father probably not
he's probably not the worst dad in the
world he's probably a pretty good dad
and he probably compensates for the
incident he has right right right by
being a better father I think this is
the first place you're kind of starting
to lose me really I think murdering your
mother
really puts you I would say I don't
think it's ideal
[Music]
but I'm wondering do do his kids still
have her that's a great question I think
they do could could someone here look at
it one of The Producers here look right
right see against digital what you have
to do is walk out with a loaded gun it's
this is not the Jamie Vernon experience
you have to walk out you have to put a
gun in there
um we kid we kid but
um I think they actually established I
think they do interesting I think they
have a pretty good relationship with him
because I did hear one theory that was
uh that the sun didn't the sun did my
mother was obsessed
[Music]
I was in a comedy central sketch about
O.J Simpson what I'd like the producers
to do right is if they can I would like
them to get up just say no J and this
may be the first time it is but OJ was a
big part of my life yeah
um this was the massive trial we watched
the verdict in fifth grade and we turned
it on in our school there was a sketch
called just say no Jay it was released
uh on Comedy Central it was one of these
sketches that they would put between
shows and I played a kid who's playing
with the DNA testing kit my father in
the sketch was playing with a Bronco and
my mother was uh doing Marcia Clark's
cookbook
who was the prosecutor in the case and
the idea was that the O.J Simpson trial
had invaded the home of every American
Family to an unhealthy degree at comedy
Central's marketing campaign was just
say no Jay stop watching the trial start
watching uh what we're doing start
watching reruns of Saturday Night Live
yeah and Mystery Science Theater and
whatever right and premium blend do we
have this let's watch just saying I
would love to Let's watch this so this
is you as a child this is the first time
this has been played on my podcast I
think
oh hey that's my boy
crushed it I've been in this business
for years
was it after that point that he told you
he'd take the next flight
yes
from Comedy Central wow so
congratulations man thank you but that's
[Laughter]
all right
um but that is where I you know this is
how big the O.J Simpson tutorial was in
the 90s it's hard to explain to these
youngins now your mother when she was
she was obsessed with the son did it
Theory yeah she in an institution at the
time or she no my mother only went in
when I was in my 20s okay all right so
she like what happens with schizophrenia
it either comes on hard in the 20s or
it's usually kind of later in life
hormonal menopause in the 40s midlife
crisis 40s things like that more common
in women than men still happens in men
um but usually it comes on early yeah
but there are cases where I think hurt
the hormonal thing I think that's a lot
of long covet not that it's
schizophrenia but it's menopausal right
right a lot of it's hormonal yeah um so
The OJ's so that was one of my first
gigs one of my first things I ever did
and we went to this house in Connecticut
and my grandmother went with me and it
was just like an all-day shoot but it
was cool yeah and it was like oh I'm in
this I'm in this thing now yeah wow so
yeah Jay OJ one of your first paying
jobs it wouldn't happen without him one
of my first paying gigs so like I'm in
the business
because of the juice
well that's an important disclosure it's
an important disclosure as a journalist
as we've covered as a journalist I want
to make sure that everybody knows that
I'm defending OJ not the ACT not the act
the totality of the person he's a job
Creator the totality of the person I
that was one of my first shoots Sesame
Street and that
and I've you know on Sesame Street I did
the polka with Snuffleupagus which
you've we've played that I think yeah
and uh but that was my fur and I did an
NYU student film I've tried to get this
guy to give me this student film it's
called truck stop I don't want to say
his name but I do but I won't and I've
tried you know Ad nauseam to get this
guy to give me uh the student to film
and he has
not released it to me he's either
embarrassed about it but it's actually a
great student film and I was nominated
for an acting award when I was like I
don't know I was like maybe nine or
something or ten or eleven what's your
role in truck stop uh it's about a a guy
who abandons his family at a New Jersey
truck stop nice dude and it's me and
this woman and my sister and we're all
abandoned and we're at this dirty Jersey
truck stop and she's trying to get money
and and it's like the hard and whatever
and then this biker gives me his
cheeseburger he's like hey you know
[__] you need a burger but I was like
thin back then I was a [__] piece
yeah dude you know so that is I was
never raped you know here's the thing
you made it out on stage I was gonna ask
I was never touched because my parents
were like my grandmother and mother were
really paranoid so if I went to a
bathroom my grandmother would stand
outside the bathroom like making sure
nothing happened now if my parents were
smarter they would have put my [__]
dude that's what I was gonna say is that
it's kind of a shame because yeah what
happened to Amanda Bynes or whoever
crazy as it I almost feel like you would
have survived I think you would have
literally made a guy sign something
before you sucked him off even at nine I
was smart
let's not advocate for this but I knew
what I was doing I knew what I was doing
um if I had to well all I'm saying is
yeah if Molly station's zero-sum game
that's right and you can save a child
who was destroyed mentally by going back
in time and getting you molested you're
not even dude you've never even met
Lewis by the way you time sign me up you
wouldn't you wouldn't even I received my
calls be hearing the gas digitals
you would be podcasting where it all
started you wouldn't become an executive
somehow you would have started as an
actor yes and that and you I do feel bad
though horrible they obviously were
kidding yeah but it is bad you know and
I'm not I'm not accusing anyone of being
molested but you do see these guys at
Cole Sprouse or whoever yeah he's
smoking the cigarettes on caller Daddy
and he's just very like you know he
seems like really out of it and I don't
know what it was right I don't know if
it's molestation it could have been
Dylan I don't know what Sprouse right oh
the the guys from uh you think it was
Adam Sandler
but it's like these these these these
kids have become successful after
Schneider on this Center yeah you can do
it suck my penis how embarrassing by the
way how embarrassing is that you're like
I got molested on the set of Big Daddy
they're like well that that tracks how
shameful but all these kids that went
through Hollywood at a young age do seem
insane yeah you don't seem to get out
alive like they all seem a little crazy
um well it's crazy it's insane to do
it's an insane thing to do like I but I
met a bunch of young I'm doing this
movie with Addison Ray yes who you know
perfect blenders and Ray like a lot of
people they're both you know Listen
People Like Us because we're hot we're
sexy We're Young we represent a lot of
things to women yeah my fan base is
mainly teenage women who are looking for
yeah
um uh um they're looking for advice and
my advice to all of them is keep your
[__] away from me and don't vote
don't even register it's not sexy is
there anything less attractive than a
woman boating
but I I'm kidding react to this
no I what I think is like
uh so by the way this Addison Ray by the
way is lovely like I hate to walk in
there and you go I bet she's a [__]
right right she's actually not well
she's like a nice like lovely person and
I guess you would be because it goes one
of two ways you're either a monster of
course or you're not she was like a
really fun cool chick that reminded me
like oh like I get it like she's also
really attractive so it's like in the
head of a straight guy I'm like oh this
is I get this you know here's my problem
with a lot of um the ear things the your
pod ped pod let's talk about it
they're very expensive and you lose them
God realism I lose them all the time I'm
on my fourth pair I wish I always had
raycons because raycon is a premium
audio brand at a perfect price point so
you can listen to what you want when you
want without breaking the bank I mean
Ray Khan is great that's a lot of good
stuff it's really good it's ear buds but
they're good they're earphones I don't
know what I can say what these are but
they are good they're cheaper
I mean they're pretty high quality pay
later options you can pay 18 and have
new headphones wow are you nuts pay
later pay later pay over three or four
years for the headphones it's fine
because the reality is here's the
reality that money that you could put
into the right kind of like you said oh
I'm gonna buy the whole weekend take
that money invest don't be an idiot
crypto yup start a business with a
friend
currency Arbitrage yeah yeah yeah any of
that stuff will be IPOs don't be stupid
that 50 000 five-star reviews
they're there they have noises noise
isolation awareness mode three
customizable sound profiles it's amazing
custom gel tips for the perfect most
comfortable in-ear fit Crystal Clear
call Quality Water and sweat resistance
eight hours of play time so go to buy
raycon.com Tim today to get 15 off your
raycon order that's buy raycon.com Tim
to score 15 off by raycon.com have you
ever used a raycon I love a raycon
nothing like a raycon folks folks I'm
not kidding around and I'm still paying
it off I'm still paying it off I chose
the layaway place
and it's done wonders I chose well this
is I'll just tell people financially
what I do you can find me if you want
doesn't matter yeah
what happened was I was going to buy the
full headphones I decided not to I
decided to put 18 down to finance the
rest I took the capital yep that I was
gonna put into the headphones I started
a Drop Shipping business after the Drop
Shipping business I took my money which
I was also um investing into
cryptocurrencies my cryptocurrencies
were showing gains I then took all my
Drop Shipping cryptocurrency money and I
started investing in real brick and
mortar businesses like weed shops and
CBD so now I own like all of the weed
shops and CBD shops in Arizona that's
awesome um I started buying into all of
these I'm private Equity now with
Blackstone Steve Schwartzman BlackRock
um I'm I work with Charlie monger and
Warren Buffett at um uh Berkshire
Hathaway of course with a lot of what
I'm doing right now I'm doing a lot of
deals with Bob Lee
who is a uh executive in San Francisco
uh who what did Bob Lee run
I don't know what did Bob I couldn't
tell you
cash app right
so I'm doing a lot right now with Bob
Lee and um none of that would have been
possible if you had to pay for these
headphones yeah rip probably he did just
get killed oh that's the guy
trying to do a bit no one knows who
probably is a finance bit
yeah I totally get this yeah she made
you she made you think for a second she
made me think for a second that I had
gone down the wrong path yeah yeah well
not that she'd be available if I chose
not that like no no no no not that like
the women that I would hook up with now
are more masculine than men of course
like the women that would be available
to me yes I was in a diner last night a
Long Island waitress walked up and I
want my producers from California and
she and we go he ordered some [__] you
know
egg whites some and I go he's from
California and she goes yeah she looks
at him she goes where's your surfboard
where's your surfboard and I'm like yeah
which is like we're also on Long Island
they surf here yes you know but I'm like
but so but she's actually and I'm doing
this this move with these kids and
they're young uh they're not kids or
adults but they're young yeah attractive
actors and they start at one time they
started to break out in song
um and that's just in the script or just
for fun oh just for fun and they started
singing Bohemian Rhapsody In The Green
Room and then you start realizing like
oh they're theater kids yeah well also
their lives have gone so well it's so
well perfect example you got to realize
if me or anyone I knew broken this song
at any moment oh my God it would be a
signal of such a mental break yeah like
such a full mental collapse my agent
they would all go and go we got to get
him in the wagon yeah get him in the
wagon give him a couple of steroid shots
and get him back out on the stage yeah
but it but those kids you would have
been beaten as a child if you started
singing unless it was like we're doing
it for money right right right but
otherwise like but their lives have been
so good and they're so attractive and
they're actually here's the thing
they're very they're all nice yeah well
they're all rich too right yeah she's
like imagine being like a rich girl like
yes it you could create you're right the
the opportunity is either like the
biggest monster of all time yeah like
this careerist climber yes who has all
the resources or would it see I don't
know her at all right I've seen like a
couple tick tocks videos but it's like
it just seems like everything has got
like you can't have a more Charmed Life
as like things turn into a rich family
and I think she'd admit that she'd go
things are good yeah yeah but she also
works her ass off she's doing acting
like there's stuff about her where
you're like a lot of them don't right
yeah and it's romantic comedy and you're
you're the two leads we are the two
leads it's called
yeah what they're doing here
Spyglass has decided to end they've
decided to end their company
it's a real throwback it's a producer
it's like it's a it's a it's a nice spin
on the Harvey Weinstein story it's a
nice spinner
it's a romance
like found it nice
what if they found it Charming when I
was like get in here get in the room I
want to be in a Tarantino movie or not
no it's I'm I play a security guard who
gets decapitated this is not I don't
want to give away the lead yeah yeah
yeah
but no I'm not so there was a click of
kids who were like they are the road but
that's also so smart though to like I
don't know what the project is at all
you told me very little about it yeah
but it's genius to use those kids in
something like that of course who are
you gonna use us yeah yeah well but it's
like you could pick like you know more
serious quote unquote actors but there
is something and I'm sure I think acting
at a certain level like if you're young
and good looking what is that like this
isn't Philip Seymour Hoffman like yeah
let's just be honest what really is
acting if you're young and hot it's like
I'm mad I'm gonna fight you cause you
look at my girl or I'm sad it's not well
I mean in a movie a slasher you don't
need but in any teeny bopper sure what
is the cast of Wednesday no offense yeah
I haven't seen it I know one of them but
like they're pouty they're pounding
today yeah and today I'm
Because by the way young people don't
like unless they've seen their family
burn in a fire they don't really have
that complex of emotions so it's not
that layered you're not you're not like
translating some really complex like
everybody talks about that scene in
White Lotus where Megan Fahey does that
kind of This brilliant thing where you
could see her like realizing all these
things on the beach just in her face
it's kind of amazing there's none of
that right [__] Wednesday
right it's just young people being hot
and being like I'm angry now now well
I'm sure I mean Eli Roth is [__] a
genius he's a killer he did hostile he's
a killer I mean he's literally no yeah
he's uh he's he loves he's a brilliant
horror director but that's what so I
without knowing it I would assume
there's some like subtext there yes
where you you you cast Tick Tock kids I
don't know what the project is like like
a good example is in like uh Starship
Troopers where they just wanted the
hottest most plastic dumb asses yeah
because they're like we're recreating
basically propaganda right like Nazi
propaganda right and so like you look at
the cast and it's like yeah the guy the
main leader looks like a gay porn actor
right you know what I mean the lead and
then it's like uh what's your face uh
Charlie Sheen's ex who's just hot as
[__] but not a good actor right so it's
like there is a time where you pick Bad
actors off yeah Denise Richards yeah
exactly but here's the Casper Van Damme
I actually think this chick is probably
pretty good interesting because
she takes it I saw her on set she
actually takes it very seriously where I
was kind of surprised and I actually
looked at it and I've been on stats I
was just on a set of one of the biggest
films coming out where I was [__] up
and yelling
screamed out and I'll be able to tell
people what movie yeah yeah hopefully my
scenes in it yeah yeah
I think it was great I think it was
great yeah I think it was great
um and I wanna I don't want to say what
movie it is it's gonna come out I know
this yeah yeah you told me about this
and uh but I so I know and it is a big
movie it's a huge movie if I'm in it
yeah
I will do something if I'm cut out I
don't deserve to be cut out no
no we'll see what happens but I observe
people
and uh she was taking it very seriously
and I think she's probably because Eli
is not gonna put somebody in who's not
good yeah he's gonna put somebody in
who's actually good and I think she
always kind of wanted to be an actress
and then she maybe just got into Tick
Tock like but do you know what I mean in
terms of directors yeah yes people
without really their full knot they're
not fully in on it you know oh for sure
like a great director yeah it's kind of
like yes you know what I'm saying that's
probably me yeah
I mean that might be me
that's maybe where what I'm doing
they're just you know
um yeah it but it's cool you know it's
interesting because I'm keenly aware
that I'm a comedian who can act right
but I'm not an actor and you know you're
not an actor when you hang out with some
of these kids where you go oh they just
have that theater kid energy that I
don't have yeah yeah we're like
literally someone will start being like
you know they'll just burst into songs
and it's it's appropriate for them yeah
and I just sat there kind of like
you know of course no theater kid energy
is brutal and it's so subtle so
self-serious too about about acting like
so so one of the kids he's like a really
good looking dude and I like I was like
talking to him and like hey you want to
hang out yeah
I'm professional you want to meet Louis
Jacob as a professional on set well they
can be cooler people
you want some supplements from on it
I don't have to start with Luis Gomez
yeah how about a couple of tickets to
the mothers but so one of these guys
I was talking to him and he like he does
his thing with his eyes where he's like
like really trying to get the scene from
Clifford up get this thing got to see
him from Clifford oh with Martin no with
Martin he's trying to be a real boy
this is a brilliant scene because this
is how the kid like they kind of look at
you like I was like oh hey man and I was
talking to him and I think he thought I
was going to say something like very
serious right so he just was like he
just looked at me like
and you're like oh they're they're just
at every moment these people are just
trying on yeah people to be trying on
right there's no authenticity that's the
thing with those kids it's like they'll
do anything they'll just like you don't
know who you're talking to but that's I
think the only way to be a really good
actor right I guarantee if you met any
of these guys it's the same thing no way
Ben Affleck is any different yeah
there's no way
they're all like that and they need to
be that's the thing it's like certain
people need to be
and I'm sure it's like it's a nice kind
of inauthentic right it's not like some
schizophrenic roaming the streets
stabbing you it's like oh this is a
person who just can kind of be a bunch
of different things and if you're super
hot I guess that's kind of the book like
if you're a super hot person yeah what's
the point of picking one personality
right right because you could kind of
get away with a lot of do whatever you
want so if you're a super hot guy you
might go I want to be a dick today I'm
going to put on a leather jacket and be
a dick do we have that Cena that's one
thing that I find weird which is you
know like your middle name
you're doing it right now can you just
act like a human boy for one minute here
look at me like a person you can't do it
for more than a few seconds look at me
like a human boy
this is so [__] good but that's the
way they are like you talk to them and
they're like
yeah yeah so they don't know how deep
the conversation can be they're kind of
like are you laying like life knowledge
because they look at me like I'm an
elderly oh of course dude they look at
me like I'm Jack Lemmon you're a wise
and chrome I'm like 38 but they they're
looking me like I'm like an old man
who's gonna say something very profound
before he dies
I gather around children they're like
gather round the wisdom and I was like
hatch scang fast
several years ago
I was there but
but that's the thing where I'm keenly
aware of like oh I'm not an actor yeah I
can act and I can do that and I would
like to do it if it was my movie If I
was in control of it yeah do you are you
doing more [__] like that I'm trying I'm
trying to act a little bit I mean this
this uh this year's been all about I
mean I've been on the road non-stop for
the last time non-stop I got I'm filming
a special may I just put a little crowd
work special if you want to go watch
sure folks uh but yeah that's that's got
to be that's kind of the goal where it's
like it would be nice to just it's fun
to fun to do some of that [__] uh yeah
I'm doing a little Indie movie I did one
scene you know you know when you do like
a romantic comedy and they meet a weird
guy right who yells at the Attractive
people on a bus yes I did one of those
scenes you know that's perfect it's
always kind of going to be something of
that and that's fine I don't need but I
feel the exact same way you do where
it's like I'm not a [__] actor I like
I like that comes like if I could do it
over like I think sometimes I go what if
I could do it over again I love these
people who go I would change nothing
it's like come on really yeah but if I
could do it over again I just love the
person I am now yeah
the jobs that I could get like that is a
plum Gig if you could just be a hot
actor who doesn't really have any like
you're just like yeah every and you meet
these people you talk to them you go and
it's not like they're
they're just like detached in this way
that like comes from just being young
and successful oh yeah and just like
just like everybody here's the thing
with hot people Everyone is always nice
to them everyone loves them and actors
especially it's like you add hot like a
hot waitress who works at like a bar
people throw things out yeah but a hot a
hot like Rich successful person oh yeah
it's it's life on easy mode there is a
collapse that happens yeah for those
that can't transition
that is a good point you know the
collapse is never too far the collapse
is not too because here's what happens
to these actors they get some heat in
L.A then they all go to New York and
they take a photo with uh like you know
in an alley smoking a cigarette looking
at the ground the rebellious face yeah
they've been in New York for 48 hours
and they act like they're like this is
It's I'm really going through it and
then what happens is they try to be like
the real actor because they've grown out
of the teeny bopper [__] rolls and
then they try to be like oh I got to be
a real actor and then some of them don't
make that leap right and then they're
[__] they're [__] big time and by
[__] I mean still rich and gorgeous
yeah yeah yeah but some of them can't
handle they might do some drugs yeah
that's the advantage of getting a career
when you're a big fat ugly piece of [__]
that's right you know it's like they
can't take it from us
they can't take it from the only one who
count is the Lord yeah which that's
around the corner the only one who can
is the Lord can you get up a little bit
of this cause process interview I just
want to see because we just want to we
want to diagnose the actor here and you
could tell and he's like literally this
by the way can we take the money back
from this call her daddy chick enough
with this 60 million dollars can we take
that back they really hit a jackpot I
mean can we take that back it's horrific
it's atrocious it's the worst thing I've
ever watched I look at it the other way
where it's like you know good for her
robbing those Swedish yes
good for her I'm just going
like I'm watching this person no one
watches that I'm watching this woman
interview and I go this is not great
she's really not great at this no
offense to her right to be honest no
offense just everything you've you've uh
in your life Barbara Walters yeah the
show was about her talking about getting
anal and I get that and that's
interesting but now she's doing these
interviews and um what about your
[__] more
it was a great means to an end
[Music]
this is what guest digital does
this is what I love about it do you mind
if I have a cigarette please have your
cigarette you know what gold let's open
the door I don't know people get people
are all oh man it's fine everyone's
smoking weed in like a studio but not a
[__] cigarette tobacco and everyone
gets like this it's fine it's [__]
fine I'm curious did you even go to like
Elementary School I did um it was off
and on
three jobs mainly
what was it or even that preface of like
do you mind if I smoke a cigarette like
everyone's cool with weed but whatever
happened to cigarettes whatever hey you
know remember when you could smoke a
cigarette in a studio it's like no
you're like you're 20 years old yeah
what happened to smacking women in the
face and smoking cigarettes why do I
gotta eat at this Lunch Counter with a
black guy
yeah because he thinks he's in Mad Men
yeah watch a little bit of this because
it's it is kind enough to it is
interesting it's it's a fine diagnosis
of the people we're talking about
was homeschooled which is great because
to be honest I did not feel like I
missed out on much everyone that talks
to me about their High School experience
I was like this sounds [__] horrible
it wasn't great it wasn't great cool but
I'm wondering do you remember when you
were in elementary school like how did
people treat you because I know you
weren't famous famous but like big daddy
you were what five yeah six and when we
were kids I don't think they really
cared too much some of them knew that we
were actors but Dylan and I uh Dylan
specifically was a huge bully so our
navigation through elementary school and
middle school we were like [__] dicks
how many bully people uh he would beat
him up
you beat him up and then I became known
as the twin that would come up and be
like I'm so sorry for my brother we I
kind of feel like that was your
character also
um Zack and Cody well I think I think
the writers on Zach and Cody took a lot
of cues from uh from you know our actual
personalities yeah by the way she gets
60 million dollars for this telling
teeth I'm ready
get me to balaclava I'm kind of ready to
go full tanky because that 60 million no
that's crazy to be like she's sitting
there in [__] claw what what is she
in those [__] what are those shoes
that Mario Batali used to wear before he
rocks Crocs she's sitting there in Crocs
close browsers smoking a cigarette and
she's like so tell me about your brother
and he's like he was a bully when he was
six yeah yeah and that gets you 16.
imagine getting beaten up by a child
actor imagine getting beat six by a
Sprouse by Cole Sprouse when they were
young by the way Mario Batali that could
be the spin this the sequel to the uh he
was thinking about Mario Batali you
could pull you could crush Mario
Batali's [__] life story now Mario
Batali can you imagine it's a biopic by
the way our friendship would end so
quickly because we'd both be reading for
that role
every fat comic in a minute would be
just sitting there and they'd be like
okay and can you imagine that horrible
Because by the way not a feature we're
talking like a lifetime lifetime
Lifetime movie of the week and like
literally they'd be like because when
you go do these additions you like slate
you say ah your name and where you live
you know and and uh and you should be
like uh Tim Dylan
the Stafford's Healthcare is from New
York whatever yeah and then you go and
then you have to read the lines you know
and then you'd be like
you like these clams hey
hey you like working here I put my whole
life into this goddamn restaurant the
least thing the last thing the least you
could do is look at me look at me yeah
look at me you want me to show you how
to make this dish that's called
tagliatelle
you want to show you come here what's
wrong
what's wrong I don't understand I
thought you liked working here I thought
you liked it they got taggly Italian
Indiana yeah let me teach you something
I thought you liked it the gnocchi has
to be done just right
get over here get over here you [__]
[__] he'll never come back by the way
Mario Batali had an apology we've talked
about it on the show but the best the
cinnamon roll
cinnamon rolls yeah he was like I'm
sorry I raped everybody but here's some
and by the way these little pastries
I mean one of the best of pop that
that's the king of the celebrity
apologies the thing about Mario Batali
is he was a good cook he was a great
chef and now he didn't even asked that
bobo that was grain right uh he did a
lamb Ragu that was lovely and he also
was
um a rapist right and an abuser of women
we're out on that we're out on that so
we I don't [__] with your colleague
here's the other thing there's a lot of
people that can make a lamb Ragu like
Nancy Silverton at Osteria Mozza in West
Hollywood okay and she does not rape
anyone not to our knowledge yeah don't
love the outfits all the time that she
does
yeah but if you had to pick one or the
other perky but I will go with that we
could see Batali to me is not like an OJ
no no no if I saw Batali now I'd be like
get the I just spit in his face I I
would actually I was never really
excited to see batala you know of all
the celebrity chefs even pre yes assault
scandals yeah
here's what the Food Network did to me I
know they created the celebrity chef but
like they also just to me
gas these chefs up so much
their egos are like insane yeah that's
pretty completely insane I get I get the
top guy like look guy fiery yes yes he
[__] rules I like him a lot it's the
Tournament of Champions great show he's
wearing Bling That a rapper couldn't
pull off guy fear is the only guy who
basically said let me make a show
out of like going to these places and
and why had no one done that yeah let's
go to these places like people talk
about
and they're really good food but also
they have health code violations yeah of
course they have health codes it's got
to be dogs they'll think they should be
yeah there's hair in it who cares well
if you've been to one in like in your
hometown that's like it was on Diners
Drive-Ins and Dives it's like it's not
good like half of them are horrible half
of them are pretending yeah like they're
like they're like I would the diner by
me which is like you know you're getting
you're getting some toothless lady and
you're still in Queens no I'm talking
about in Baltimore where I was growing
up yeah the diner by me
it's you know it's fine right it's like
the fries are in the freezer the
everything is Frozen like it's just
right you go there it's you go there
it's it's 2 A.M yeah some toothless
ladies trying to get our kids back is
gonna [__] up half of your order right
right uh and then there's a picture on
the wall of guy fiery and they have like
uh their Seafood Tower you know what I
mean it's like you you brought in you
bought a Seafood Tower from a different
restaurant right and served the guy when
he was here they'll literally be like
our lump crab cakes it's like you don't
have lump crab cakes here you get
pancakes and [__] sausage here a lot
of it's fake it's all fake and one of
them was sad I walked to one of them I
was on the road I literally don't
remember where I was I walked in one of
them and the proprietor had died and it
was literally just a picture of him and
Guy Fieri and then he was like bald with
cancer and they're like all right be
Rick I'm like okay this is a little
rough
yeah that's a tough wall yeah it's a
tough wall I don't want to see this
while I'm eating chicken cacciatore yeah
but I mean the Food Network to me like I
remember the Heyday of it was when me
and my grandparents would watch Emerald
show and he was like Emerald live and
he'd be like bam of course bam and you
know everybody was so excited to be on
Emerald live and uh he was the
Forerunner he was the Forerunner he was
the big you know to me I still think
Emeril Lagasse
you know if we're looking at celebrity
chefs he's up there in the top yeah he's
Jordan he's Jordan and guy is LeBron
yeah it's a generational thing that's
right and then and Guy Fieri I don't
know if he was he a chef probably yeah
dude I hated Bobby Flay I still hate I
love watching Beat Bobby Flay to root
against him I hate I hate the premise of
that show where he's like let's go find
something that's being cooked the same
way for 40 years and let me see if I can
beat it because I'm a [__]
it's like ah he also is a [__] getter
though you know that's another reason he
does [__] a lot to hate Bobby Flay and
didn't he uh didn't he marry that rich
chick didn't he marry a rich chick I
don't know he might have well I'm not
I'm not a baby Flathead I like Emerald
I could [__] with Lydia Bastianich from
folidia New York sure that [__] could
carve a [__] chicken with a knot like
I loved Lydia of course Del posto
felidia she's a gangster Lydia
Bastianich Ina Gartner bear for
contestants Barefoot Contessa gangster
frankliotti the best bit about that
brilliant yeah um uh I'm a big chopped
head personally yeah people like
chopping Tom kaliko's okay Top Chef fine
he was good he was good uh What and that
Paula Dean was the one that fell from
Grace which yeah she was exactly what
you thought she would be yeah yeah
it's like if she didn't say the n-word
that would be more surprising and she
was just abusing her staff yeah and
making them dress up as slaves I think
set up what Paula Deen got canceled she
said the n-word as well which can't do
that you can't but look at it but it's
Paula Deen it's oh down ho you want you
want somebody whose whole thing is about
authentic Southern yeah nothing's more
you're dropping a couple ends yeah in
the kitchen nothing's more authentic
than Paula Deen but I think that is [__]
I think she got canceled for making the
yeah Paula Deen use the N word wanted
let's get the the headline up thanks
gentlemen
heard wanted slaves to serve away I mean
that's out of control I mean okay get
wanting the slave a true southern
plantation style wedding would include
waiters dressed as slaves Dean says in a
deposition that's awesome so she her
argument was again Ferris militude she
was like we're doing it real we're doing
it right can you imagine by the way I'd
be that much of a racist that you're
being deposed like you're a deposition
and you have to argue that point you're
like yeah
I don't like it I I don't like it when
they made when they made Schindler's
List yeah the guards had to be racist
towards the Jews yeah I'm I'm making I'm
making a a realistic dinner here
southern style wedding of course I'm
gonna have slaves why would I not hire
black people and make them dress up as
slaves and by the way the uh the Jackson
subsequently asked Dean what type of
uniform she preferred she used servers
the servers to wear well what I would
really like is a bunch of little oh my
god oh a little n words to wear long
sleeve white shirts black shorts and
black bow ties you know in the Shirley
Temple days they used to tap dance
around oh my Shirley Temple Paula
laughed and said now that would be a
true southern wedding wouldn't it
because but we can't do that because the
media would be happy about that
cancel culture is going too far it's
like the goddamn woke media won't let me
get a bunch of little n-words tap
dancing it's like God Jesus Christ
it has to be an authentic Southern
wedding you know like in a Shirley
Temple movie yeah
literally just she's conflating a bunch
of different kinds of races yeah yeah
she just she's covering the races it's
racist Fusion it's an authentic but she
really just wants Al Jolson like black
face like you know what I mean she's
like it's an authentic Southern wedding
right but you know we have a Jew and
blackface singing jazz standards [__]
crazy man it's crazy but you know that's
I think part of the problem when you
steep yourself so much in your culture
that you can't get out like I think that
sometimes you need to just take a breath
ask one black person how they feel about
that yeah like ask one person just one
just run it by them like super casually
go let me ask you let me ask you a
question
sit down for this
if I said to you we're doing a southern
style wedding and I want some you know
black people they're gonna be servers at
the wedding and I wanted them to kind of
you know dress as slaves and tap dance
with that would that be what do you
think is there any part of that that's
the best thought yeah so is there any
part of that that would offend you oh
the whole thing oh all of it all of it
I also don't understand why anyone would
get married on a plantation that's wild
to me too yeah if you believe in like
yeah that's a that's a bad that's some
bad energy if you believe in energy at
all yeah it's like a lot of not chill
stuff has happened right there it's kind
of like just saying like we're very
excited we're getting married on an
Indian burial right right we're going so
excited we're going to Auschwitz to have
our nuptials uh there's a Navajo burial
ground and we've decided that me and my
wife are gonna go down there and it is
going to be amazing yeah yeah yeah yeah
no but it's um well people will do that
you know I've talked about it I I've
made this joke it's probably Real by now
and I'm trying to know there's old
hotels and but people will start doing
like weddings in prisons yeah a bunch of
white pictures sitting in the electric
chair with champagne yeah I mean 100 I'm
like we'll probably Outlaw capital
punishment although maybe not but like
eventually we might and then you know
like these things are going to be
tourist attractions and somebody's gonna
be like let's get married in the [__]
death chamber right right right I guess
yeah you're even saying it and it's like
uh Alcatraz I would love that imagine We
Rent Out Alcatraz a great party the
whole [__] well I think they're gonna
close Rikers yeah they say I think
Rikers might get closed because Rikers
is a nightmare yeah they just have
people there like with on parking
tickets yeah they just don't get access
to Plumbing I don't understand like the
way this this criminal justice system
works to me is so great and I'm not a
guy that says let everybody out if
they've done bad things but like the
amount of people that are in for like I
smoked a joint especially now I smoked a
blunt I couldn't pay my
C for hopping the turnstile of a train
and now I'm in this prison well don't
worry don't worry there's eight cops
there to check on that right it's like
who gives a [__] yeah about Subway
turnstiles yeah yeah I think I don't
think you can let stuff like that get
completely out of control but I also
don't think you should be putting people
in jail for years or people can't like
well those cops don't do [__] they play
Candy Crush and every once in a while
like a teenager comes along and they're
like all right let's [__] up his record
for how he returns well it should be a
misdemeanor it should be something quick
where you can kind of get out but then
there's certain things where it's like
you know if you throw someone in front
of a train that should be yes
it's gonna be a little yeah um you know
but yeah it's funny man it's funny to
watch
I don't even know what uh what is on the
can we bring up the Food Network
schedule now I'm just curious It's like
what would still be on this they got
I'll tell you right now they got a lot
of Beat Bobby Flay they got a lot of
they got a lot of Tournament of
Champions there's nothing better than
the Food Network on a summer day
when you should be outside
you know what I mean like there's
nothing that feels particularly worse
than watching like the Food Network on a
summer day well it's my favorite like uh
Road thing to watch oh you got diners
you got triple D going Alex First
America yeah they're really trying I
like Alex what is Alex first American I
like Alex Garner Shelly she's a really
good cook but they they're putting in a
lot of stuff but she's one of my
favorite Chopped judges
they always did this thing where they
wanted like a lot of triple d's they
always wanted comedians on the Food
Network and then they like met us and
then they were like oh we don't want
that at all we actually don't want that
at all that's a huge mistake right right
that's a massive mistake we don't want
that at all I'm not sorry we even
suggested that star versus hulkiest
where can people find you and see you
and I'm a part of your life yes uh I got
uh podcast davi's world come check it
out come do it sometime Timmy uh but I
have a new crowd work half hour yes just
a little put together I put it together
a little little bonus special uh free on
YouTube right now stavi baby on Twitter
stavi baby two on Instagram I'm on tour
the fat Rascal tour still a couple
tickets left to the special the special
taping in Austin and then in the fall
I'm just I'm all over the place playing
a couple theaters are you doing
Paramount awesome special [__] yeah
awesome I'm really excited for that you
will enjoy that timedelacomedy.com we're
on the road until mid-june uh if you are
interested instead uh if you're not who
cares [__] off if you're not if you're
not it's okay yeah it is what it is but
timbilacomity.com to get uh tickets to
those shows thank you so much dude thank
you I really appreciate it great to see
you buddy